instead of saying there might be
something wrong with a framework the
move of cosmologist was to say there
must be something else because otherwise
our Theory would not be correct
[Music]
so what I would like to do in the next
20 minutes or so is to show how it is in
fact possible as a hypothesis that in
advanced modern science as we know it
trying to follow the scientific method
in good faith can
be led into a kind of self-reinforcement
of errors and get stuck
so the general question that interests
me why I waded into this topic is what
happens at the very limit of knowledge
where physics and metaphysics intersect
cosmology is situated right here it is
right where science on the one hand and
religion or myth if you will on the
other bleed into each other inevitably
and as I will try to show in the
following
an excessive belief in the scientific
method itself can also lead to a kind of
zealotry in its own right
just a few words about how I came to
this somewhat unusual perspective uh so
in my long academic journey and most of
it did in Canada
I was blessed and cursed you could say
by doing all my doctoral research and
postdoctoral research across disciplines
not inside of any particular one not
inside of philosophy or science studies
as so I was investigating the role of
metaphysics in the formation of modern
science
but I also followed uh uh what's known
as science in action inspired by the
work of French Anthropologist Bruno
LaTour and many others trying to
understand how science moves and works
as well
so the traditional perspective and
philosophy of science is that science is
about realism versus idealism different
ways of approaching truth
but really science is about doing it's
about producing acceptable research it's
about convincing other scientists it's
about winning funding to do research and
so on so science
as I was trying to map out how cosmology
and physics work it's not simply about
truth seeking it's a production of
knowledge it's an industry and I was
trying to map this out across
theoretical landscapes not in any one
individual silo
but as you may know in Academia
everything is governed by specialization
and the greater the specialization the
greater the potential blind spot I had a
PhD supervisor who used to argue that
every discipline inevitably loses sight
of its foundational problem over time
so he used to say if you want to
understand politics do not study
political science if you want to
understand the economy do not study
economics and so on
and so I used to wonder
if you want to understand the cosmos
should you study cosmology
obviously there's no particular career
path for this kind of perspective uh
like across the human and Natural
Sciences but this is how
I came at this this question of
cosmology and so just from the outside
as I'm sure many of you know cosmology
is very different from other Sciences in
a very fundamental way the scope of the
subject matter covers the largest extent
imaginable literally and it does so
based only on our own local place within
it so unlike physics in the in the micro
scale
we cannot do repeated experiments under
control conditions we're looking for
patterns in the sky and single
observations
just the scope of the macrophysical
universe as we know it is at least 20 to
30 orders of magnitude higher than the
lower scale of theoretical physics at
the micro level so this means there's
practically no accessible part of the
universe
where we can do manipulations or and the
time scales involved are also millions
of times longer than any human life so
all of this obvious limitations and it's
possible to question already here
based on this how cosmology could be a
science at all I mean you could turn
this around and say it's quite
impressive that we can do anything at
all and make any kinds of predictions
from the extremely limited region of
space that we're in that's visible
and how we can even measure it with some
kind of confidence
so just to consider the scale for a
second
to measure distance in space
we use certain light phenomena in the
sky that we figure are quite precise and
we use them to guide us
and so in order to measure measure space
we need a theory and confidence that
this theory is universally applicable
so what it means is that cosmologists
don't simply observe and measure
distances
they interpret them Independence on the
model they use to calculate this
distance so there is this is something
I've written about elsewhere but there's
a self-reinforcing dynamic at work here
where actually the further out in the
universe you go the more model dependent
you become so try to run these
calculations with a Canadian physics
Professor that I collaborate with and we
found that you know when you get very
very far into the observable universe
the difference between models can mean
25 to 50 percent difference in what the
scale and the size is
how far how far apart galaxies really
are depends on the model you use
now this is rarely discussed because
scientists have more or less agreed to
just use only one model so we are left
with you know remarkably precise numbers
for distances and this model is called
the standard model of cosmology
sometimes known as the concordance model
or the Lambda CDM model
now we all know and are familiar with
the idea of the big bang and that's easy
enough to understand
and this might be a reason why
this idea has been able to capture the
imagination of three generations already
but the standard model is like actually
quite a complicated structure
so been working to map this out this is
one way to represent it
I'm not sure if you're familiar with the
childhood game Jenga in which you build
a tower of different blocks on top of
each other and if any of the blocks you
can pull out one of the blocks and then
the other ones will fall apart
in my mind the standard model of
cosmology is a little bit like this we
have built building blocks on top of
each other so on top of the Newtonian
Basics that we have confidence for
within our own solar system up to a
certain degree
we have a
with the standard model the key is
a general relativity model a specific
version of it that assumes Evolution
over time
and we've
couple that with uh
this idea of the cosmic origin the
finite origin in time which is
hypothesis that you know the universe
started with a big bang that is the main
framework
and then two key interpretations in the
20th century were hailed as evidence of
this framework first the redshift of
galaxies
was taken to mean that space is
expanding usually we hear about space is
expanding what is noteworthy is that
this is an interpretation it's a
consensus interpretation of a light
phenomenon
uh this expansion of space would work
really well with this general relativity
model that assumes evolution in time
so this was a the the so-called
discovery of the redshift of galaxies
and the expansion of the universe was
key to making scientists move to an
evolutionary model of the universe
then the second thing uh that happened
was very important in the 1960s was the
discovery of the so-called micro Cosmic
microwave background radiation this was
discovered it was interpreted as a
residue of the Big Bang
uh
I'm not going to go into more detail
about those things here but just want to
point out that
these observations or interpretations
and really only those two
shifted the entire theoretical framework
for the universe in the middle of the
20th century
so it's with these building blocks and
these two key interpretations it became
a professional discipline with big
research budgets and so on that's the
foundation that's the only
that's the only professional cosmology
that we've had prior to this it used to
be you know astronomers and philosophers
wondering about how space was outside of
our own solar system
um it's the only model that we really
have worked with
in the last 50 years
so standardized cosmology assumes the
universe has a finite origin in time and
this is what's described by the general
relativity model
a more fundamental tenet of this is that
the claim that mathematical laws that we
deduce from our own Galaxy our own
neighborhood of the universe apply
University and this means that because
we assume that they have this infinite
or until the end of the universe kind of
reach
that we can know the entire temporal
extent of the Universe from its creation
until today that we can
calculate the time and then we have the
framework so now we just have to fill in
the stars and the galaxies
it's just puzzle work from here is the
proposition
there's a very bold project and it's
painting a grand picture and we found
lots of data to match this picture
unfortunately we also made a lot of
observations that contradict this
picture
so one of them as you know one so uh
we just debated this morning dark matter
in another panel that's one of the
blocks that's been added on top to
account for discrepancies between
theories and observation so dark matter
was essentially invented in the middle
of the 20th century or in the latter
half of it as an explanation for why our
observations of galaxies
didn't fit this mathematical model
instead of saying there might be
something wrong with a framework the
move of cosmologist was to say there
must be something else because otherwise
our Theory would not be correct so there
must be this thing
inflation uh is something that was
invented you see it at the back there it
was invented as an explanation for how
the universe could possibly come into
the shape that we can observe today from
this big bang that's a mathematical
theory for how that could have happened
Dark Energy was then invented to account
for this found a sensible acceleration
of space and so on so all of it is
building blocks on top of each other
um
to sort of create patches on what the
original framework could not do step by
step so today there are some crises in
cosmology and challenges some of these
upper blocks such as dark matter that's
been debated here but very few
like very few scientists want to
question the blocks below
the ones that hold up these dark matter
and dark energy blocks and I would argue
from my research that this this
reluctance to question the blocks
underneath is not because they are
themselves so solid and proven Beyond
doubt but rather because if any of them
are in doubt or even slightly wrong then
this entire Jenga Tower will fall apart
so it's just too too difficult to start
wading into what this stuff is built on
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas